Olympic gold medal gymnast that's alley
racin is calling for an independent
investigation to the alleged mishandling
of sexual abuse allegations against
former team dr. Larry Nasser in a
statement on twitter Raceland said this
the US Olympic Committee is still not
acknowledging its own role in this mess
so far more than 100 women and girls
have testified against Nasser ahead of
his sentencing more are expected to
speak out today dr. Jon LaPook has been
following this story and joins us once
again at the table to discuss John hi
good morning Gail the Chairman vice
chairman and treasurer of USA Gymnastics
resigned yesterday under pressure from
the US Olympic Committee but victims
have criticized USA Gymnastics Michigan
State University and the USOC for not
doing enough to stop Nasser when the
first complaint surfaced years ago my
hate towards you is uncontrollable Larry
now sir I hate you fifteen-year-old
em'ly Ann Miller was possibly Larry
Nasser's final victim she says he
treated her monthly since she was 10
years old her last appointment in 2016
just a week before Nasser was fired from
Michigan State University MSU sports
medicine charged me for those
appointments my mom is still getting
billed for appointments where I was
sexually assaulted a Michigan State
University spokesperson said Miller's
allegation is being addressed and
patients of NASA with outstanding bills
will not be built when girls came
forward and told an adult the until
student listen why didn't they listen
victims have not only taken aim at NASA
and Michigan State but also at USA
Gymnastics and the US Olympic Committee
organizations they believe mishandled
complaints about NASA how are we to
believe in change when these
organizations aren't even willing to
acknowledge the problem during her
testimony last Friday Olympian Aly
Raisman called out USA Gymnastics in the
US Olympic Committee for standing by as
athletes were abused yesterday the US
Olympic Committee released a statement
saying it had been engaged in
discussions with USA Gymnastics which
led to three board resignations race
Minh responded by blasting the committee
for shamelessly taking credit
the Olympic Committee is still not
acknowledging its own role in this mess
zero accountability both USA Gymnastics
and the United States Olympic Committee
have been very quick to capitalize and
celebrate my success but did they reach
out when I came forward
no the USOC said yesterday the Olympic
family failed these athletes and they
must continue to ensure this never
happens again
USA Gymnastics also suspended a former
olympic head coach John Garrett
yesterday the owner of twist star's gym
in Michigan USA G did not give a reason
for the suspension but many women
alleged court records abuse by NASA
occurred there yet her did not respond
to our request for comment those
statements were so hard to watch John
you could really feel and see the pain
and the anger in the room you were there
what was it like what was like take us
inside
you know Gail I've been following this
for a year and this brought my
understanding to a whole other level
well you could not see from home was
looking at the audience the faces the
devastation the tears the anger and one
father addressing matter directly you
felt the fury and then this moment that
I really almost lost it where a young
woman was testifying and giving her
statement and behind her her parents and
at one moment she got so emotional she
had a halt and stopped and her mother
just reaches out and touches the small
of her back I will tell you what's
uplifting to because I spoke to a bunch
of the women afterwards they were
hugging each other they were supporting
each other physically and emotionally
and I asked several of them what what
was it like listening to each other
statements and immediately the answer
empowering does Nasr have children see
there I think he has three children he's
married and this is just all hard to yea
comprehend your reporting has been
incredible thank you John
thank you